Any person who hears a Christian, a Jew, or any other non-Muslim say, "
Remember God," will not eat it. "Do not eat of that over which the
name of God has not been invoked." Yes, by God, yes, by
God, so I will not
eat it. But if you hear a Jew or a Christian say, "I will
eat," and that's it. So don't come here and ask me why I'm not eating it, saying, "
Because he's
pious." No, he's misguided. Don't you dare say he's pious. He's not pious. He's not pious. You
ask me, "Do you eat?" I
say no. I say no, but not because he's pious. No, not because he's pious. I'm not saying he's pious because
if you say he is pious, then you're contradicting the Messenger of
God. Yes, by God, if you say I don't eat
because he's pious, then you're contradicting the Messenger of God, as if you're
saying the Prophet was without piety. Why? Because the Prophet ate
from their sacrifices, and we will say this. So don't you dare say, "
I stopped eating because I'm pious." That would be saying Adam wasn't
pious. But if you come and tell me, "No, no, I don't eat
their meat, I don't even cook it, and I don't drink water from his
hand if he holds the cup like that,"  It's over for
me, it's over for me. I'm not a child, I'm disgusted.
Look, I'm telling you, I'm disgusted, man. I
see it, I don't like its smell, I don't like it,
I'm not lucky, and I'm disgusted by it, the smell, the look, everything.
I'm disgusted, I don't even like cinnamon. It's not just
that, it's many things, but I'm
disgusted by them in particular. If it's like a glass of water, I wouldn't
drink it. I mean, once my kids asked me for a cake, so I was passing by and
I saw a shop. I'd bought from it for the first time, it was
called
La Palma, you know? So I thought, "Something fancy, something really." I
went in and said, "I want this cake." He said, "This one." He just stood there picking. I
looked around and I saw the pictures you
know, the ones of them, and their dad, and the one holding I do
n't know, a snake, crawling, and I don't know what, and everyone
in the shop was crosses, crosses, crosses. That's it, I'm done.
I told him to bring it, and he started filling
the box. I took the box of cakes and left. There it was,
cakes! No chicken or chick. There was
this fat, plump guy, handing out cakes, selling cakes. I gave
him the box of cakes and said, "Peace be upon
you." I know, man, that's just how I am.
But I don't go around telling
people I'm a pious person. No, that's not a pious person, not a pious person, not a pious person.
Why? Because God will make it easy for me. The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, is finished. You come and ask yourself, "Some
people say, 'I don't eat,' and the pious person..." No, that's not a
pious person. Like I told you, that's a lack of understanding. You say "pious person"
because you're insulting the Prophet. Why? Because in the
hadith of Bukhari, where the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, was mentioned, he was going to
eat a sheep that had been slaughtered by a Jew
and a Jewish woman. Didn't he have a pious person then?
Can anyone say that? No one can say that. Every sheep
was slaughtered by a Jew and a Jewish woman.  And he didn't give them a test,
like Ibn Hajar said. He didn't ask them, "Did you
name it Allah or not?" And his brother, his brother, was being overly strict. He said, "No, ask him
first." Who are you asking, man? Who are you
asking, man? Who told you to
ask him? Who told you to ask him? Where did you get this
from? Who guided you to it?
Look, Al-Hasan said, "Say, 'And Allah knows best what they say.'" And the
Prophet himself didn't ask the one who told him, "Did you name it
or not?" He put the sheep down and sat down to eat. So,
feeding the People of the Book is permissible for you. So, you sit down to
eat. So, you sit down to eat. There's no
problem. Don't call me pious. The issue
of dealing with them is that the Prophet dealt
with them. The Prophet died with his armor pawned to a Jew.
What's the problem? I'm not telling you not to do anything unless it's
war. I mean, it's not permissible to buy and
sell with the Jews. It's not permissible to buy and sell with the Jews.
But then you come and talk to us about Peter and George here. No, he
sells to me, and I buy to him. I buy from the
Christians, by God.  Look, I'm telling you I don't accept,
but look what I'm telling you, I'm telling you I don't accept,
but buy my heart from them, that's none of your
business. So, once when I was sitting with one
of them, and unfortunately he was a Muslim, one of those who
love them and are guaranteed entry into Paradise, and a sheikh too,
when I was talking to him, he wanted to trap me, saying, "You
love them?" I said to him, "I'm asking you, do you love them?" He said, "
Yes." I said to him, "May God gather you with him." He said, "No, I don't love them,
but you're
talking to me about love, so I'll ask him. I'll ask him, 'Does he love the
Prophet?' If he says yes, I love him." The other one, when he saw me
put him in this position, said, "Don't drag me into this."
Well, you want to drag me into it. When we
talk, all they ever say is, "Do
you love them?" Ask them
before you ask me. I'll ask him. Do
n't try to fool me. I'll ask him the same question and
keep it on the same level. I believe in Jesus and
Mary. Do you believe in
Muhammad? That's the question.  It became pointless for me, so
when he told me not to involve him in
this, I told him, "Just don't play games with me. Let's stick to our own path.
What do you want from me? Justice? You'll find it with me. Your rights? You'll find them with me. My
Islam tells me, 'I will not wrong you, nor
destroy you, nor transgress against you. I hate you, but I will not transgress against your
wealth or your honor.'
God hates the Jews and gave them compounded wrath, so they incurred
wrath upon wrath. And yet, you have 10 verses in
Surah An-Nisa' about the Jews."